hello everybody my name is markiplier
and today we're gonna be doing a
feel-good video where I am gonna get
creative again and buy again I mean I
just got creative with the UH the fan
art video [__] who's calling me what
people's I see this tweet you think you
can do that huh you think you can tweet
cute pictures and may not know about it
huh hey Dad adorable but not what we're
doing right now not not worrying about
this right now not now right now not
right now not right now so what I'm
gonna be doing is I'm going to be
getting a little creative and if you see
here I've got a lovely Twitter layout
for myself that I made in five minutes
or one I didn't even make it it's a
picture but what I'm gonna do for you
guys is I'm gonna tweet out for you guys
to tell me something that you love
something that you really like in your
everyday life and I'm gonna make you a
Twitter layer a Twitter layout about
that thing whatever it may be could be
dicks before the end of this video I'm
probably gonna end up making a dick
layout of some sort or or a boob layout
or a butt layout but something something
tells me there's gonna be some wholesome
wholesomeness to this so I'm gonna tweet
out tell me something that you really
love I'm gonna make you guys some sweet
Twitter now I'm gonna I'm gonna keep it
cryptic I'm gonna keep it cryptic at
force tell me something that you really
love tell me something that you really
really love choose wisely I'm going to
be making something out of it people are
gonna be figured that I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be mocking what they love
mercilessly do they know that I intend
to give them a gift because I have right
here nothing absolute nothing in
darkness I've got emptiness inside my
soul I've got absolutely no one and no
friends and no and love mold and also
I've got a Photoshop document oven with
1500 pixels by 500 pixels which is the
exact size of a Twitter layout oh-o-oh
penis target about a penis loud Oh
Oh Oh you should have chosen a bit more
wisely than that because now the first
one that I'm gonna make is gonna be a
penis layout and I thought this is gonna
be a wholesome experience for the whole
family
now after Google search penis oh boy
this is that's a lot of penis that is
whoa that is penis that is a bunch of
penis all right yep that is penis man I
can't believe I have to save a bunch of
images of penis well where will I put it
on my computer I definitely don't have
pictures of penis anywhere okay I gotta
get it gotta get a nice background for
this my god that's so going in this
layout hang on
I'll show you in a second I mean I won't
because it's all gonna be blurred out
but your you will see it you'll see it
you'll see it I have no idea why this
this stock photo exhibit good love stock
photos oh my god they're the funniest
[__] okay this is gonna give this gonna
be prominently featured over Hitler six
look at this [__] [__] made this stock
photo why did this need to be made I
have no idea but that's gonna be that's
gonna be the main crux of this and let's
just try to I'm gonna try to speed
gooble dable this [__] well it's gonna
be a grayscale style thing I think the
funniest stock photo I've ever seen in
my life
the rest isn't as funny cuz it's just
penises yeah I gotta get the mr. t dildo
in here cried dildo in here flip that
around I could be this could be just you
a background oh man you know something
that's just a little more whimsical see
put a new layer on there let's make this
normal I
oh man oh man I'm I'm so glad and at the
same time not glad that this was the
first
thing that cropped up out of this
[__] oh man oh
they chose poorly oh man they they chose
poorly
oh boy oh boy
oh man Oh No okay what's the coup de
Grasse the crew de Kock here got to get
the crew to crew to CAC here and wait
for it yeah that's a I think this one
might need a blur as well yep oh I can
have that one I can have that one back
paddling ah yes
crossing swords okay that's one down
oh man oh that is funny wait oh I forgot
I need to put I need to put their
username in here at movie Phil and move
Phil that was it okay put a stroke on
that bad boy ain't no one claiming this
for their own put that on there
you chose boy oh man oh wow
Oh enjoy your new Twitter layouts it's
the perfect size oh no oh yes okay that
is one down one down I didn't know it'd
take that long oh man oh boy oh man are
they gonna put it well it's just white
space so far I'm assuming that's that's
uh I'm nineteen mark shut up I love I
did it all right that's one jeez I
commend to get a lot more than this but
I got I'm [__] I'm such a good
Squidward that is good that is good that
is pretty dang good all right I need to
start a new layer completely let's just
white it out BLAP I can work with this
so if I'm not mistaken Nick hasta lows
like Squidward if if I'm not mistaken I
might be mistaken but I'm I don't think
I am mistake I'm pretty sure pretty sure
that mistaken is the opposite of what I
am so they like I'm not nearly done I'm
not nearly done at Nick underscore asta
lows okay all right okay okay we got it
we got him we got him oh hell yeah we
got him you're welcome you're welcome
you're welcome all right let's try to
get a wholesome one let's try to get
some nice wholesome wholesome all
there's a lot of puffs oohs I've got an
idea for this one
no don't save that no need to save it
I've got it locked in the memory banks
all right let's start a new one here
let's start just fresh layer I've got an
idea
so bring in a little bit of life okay
you know what I'm gonna roll with it
it's gonna be fine oh boy oh boy but I'm
gonna save that oh man
dog Oh hot Oh laughs here we go
you're welcome congratulations
don't think there's any way gonna
improve that well to be proven wrong oh
my god okay let me see what the the with
the responses on some of these things
it's simple ease oh man you turned a
great piece of artwork into a beautiful
piece of artwork I can only imagine his
adorable laughs as he made it I'm sorry
so just love this guy god I love stock
photos Oh can't believe my hero
markiplier not only just replied to me
but made me a header crossing that one
off the bucket list oh oh that's so
sweet oh thank you this is thank you
this is incredible my new header for
sure
in was watching Steven universe when
Mark replead so I didn't notice I can't
be Arthur oh that's just I made it why
does it make me laugh I don't know maybe
that's why but either way that is all
the time I got for this one I only
managed to make three of them but man it
takes longer than I thought it takes a
while to be creative who would have
thought but thank you everybody so much
for watching and thank you for joining
me on this adventure if you want to see
more stuff like Annis I want to see it
too so let me know so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]